[Music]
and Suicide Squad news oh that was a
terrible terrible terrible mercenary
that ever seen I've never seen that many
Academy award-winning actors in the most
horrible film ever I never watched it no
don't do that
why does if it's that bad why do people
all want to be Harley Quinn and [ __ ]
Joker and stuff did you [ __ ] a costume
lock on your dog yeah direction the
character designer look is dope yeah but
at the execution horrifying looks like a
hot girl so bad if I knock on do it the
acting was good the writing was battered
by literally Megan thought this movie
was named hot but no chops
submitted by kaliba clue I think believe
it Kali see a Liva that's a no-name
artificial sweetener here's to two
people having sex addresses Batman
characters were shot by police during a
raid at an Australian nightclub wow
there's so many words that did not fit
together at all and that was so anything
I won more times I don't do I register
what you say but two people having sex
dressed as Batman sorry
characters were shot by police during a
raid at an Australian nightclub
interesting so two people were [ __ ]
during a raid in a nightclub that they
were dressed as Batman characters so I
just said that
exactly wait which Batman characters
versus maybe the cops hated the movie
was it was it Dick Grayson and Batman
like that is Joker and Penguin
Joker and Harley Quinn so that's a
really bad Joker yeah because I could
have done that I don't think may have
Miller or something yeah it does
why are you wearing like douchey glasses
maybe he just couldn't get the same ones
will be beep down oh come on man sugar
control oh yeah his [ __ ] finger man
that's why he probably got shot because
carry a gun cause he was carrying a gun
he had his finger on the trigger I need
Chris meter this couple they were at
this swingers party at his nightclub and
[Music]
I love swings that's when the about 40
police officers just stormed into the
nightclub it must have smelled terrible
in there I just I just wouldn't have
rated it I just been like so what's
going on 15 people are [ __ ] in there
okay who's next I'm not going gross so
the cops were saying that they they had
reports of a man that had a weapon and
so that's the reason why they raided
that night clubs and so once they go in
they see this couple they see Joker with
his toy gun and according to the police
he pulled out the gun and pointed at the
cop quite analyse what yeah I could see
him doing this to him
so then huh there are about a hundred
people there so that's a lot of any
[ __ ] just gross that's a [ __ ]
buffet yeah in the buffet of AIDS yeah
there's the three fingers on Kaiser hood
hahaha well if you're [ __ ] all that
hexade don't you I'm pretty sure I think
before those swing of things you gotta
get like papers and sugar he doesn't
want the point of entry so much safer
because they all test and they're always
up to date with that stuff no I know
this I rather [ __ ] a Dutch hooker then
[ __ ] a swinger why because a swinger I
don't know nothing about but a hooker
has papers the legal ones they are
tested frequently goes with government
regulated they go to the hospital all
that stuff a swinger on the other hand
you never know it's just casual you're
right mm-hmm
she just could have sucked a herpe dick
right before she came over here in the
back of a McDonald's alley so could the
hooker but they're doing weekly checkups
okay they do get weekly checkups but
they use a condom and they suck it so
you minimalize the ravine but everything
you still didn't get like a condoms not
protecting the whole you know saying
yeah but yeah the nose in the end of the
chin could still touch it I'm just gonna
saran wrap my whole body before I go
into a swingers club stuff us out now of
course I would you go to UM between
abortion or them of course I am
so clip my wife why would you go to
scream your part again just don't go to
get
dick-suck with saran wrap on of course
you never got oh yeah that's right you
don't know what it feels like but
messages like the Cinnabon has to be
exact laughing but it's dangerous though
because you can't just protect your dick
you got to protect your mouth you got to
protect your eye you got to protect your
nose you got to protect your ears you
got to protect every single hole every
home okay but sir
so and then when you actually come yep
the saran wrap is just gonna it's gonna
come inside yeah it's when you try to
sneeze with your mouth closed me up
uh-uh exactly it is just all here that's
exactly what it is
it's you're going to come and it's going
to seep when you're upside down like
this why are you all set down sorry it's
more more time he's doing a handstand
against the wall [ __ ] crazy though
I've seen a swingers like actual club
underground warehouse they booked out
this this place to do like a birthday
party right and then me and my buddy can
were like invited to do some DJ work
there so we went and the whole place
just had beds like rows and rows of beds
just like all along got a nice or dirty
I mean maybe there was some [ __ ] stains
but they were like clean they didn't
smell like any no black light but
imagine okay so you know like those Las
Vegas lounge pools you know how they
have those cabanas right yeah they were
all cabanas on the side with just mad
beds and in the in the other rooms
there's just all these different private
rooms with like handcuffs on the wall
with beds and it was like you could
probably feel like 200 people there Wow
so the whole place was just made for
[ __ ] yeah and it was all part of like
a group it's like a club that they all
pay money for and it's like but it's not
easy for single guys to get in you have
to go on with a couple as a couple yeah
just be a bunch of dudes in there yeah
true yeah but then I asked the guy that
owned the plate is there like a glory
hole in front of you not a stripper
poles everywhere and just it was like
crazy it was like or I imagine like a
furniture store it was like a huge
warehouse
it's like a Costco it was not and then I
asked a guy that owned the place where I
was like how long has been doing this
for and all that he goes oh like we
probably had this for maybe ten years Oh
ten years and then I was like how um how
big is like this membership and he goes
oh we probably have about a thousand
people
oh I would have asked how long's cleanup
yeah or do the cleanup actually have
minimal cleanup
you go in there with a black light it's
all gonna be white oh there's like one
spot so clean there was a lot of black
light because it was like a club
environment but I didn't see anything
I'm sure it wasn't black lights probably
just me only they probably need to clean
up from the park so much days to bring a
[ __ ] hosen and there's black - laser
or fire yeah and I'm pretty sure they
don't check for like STDs or anything
yes they just go and line up you get
AIDS just walking in the air Hilton tiny
the names I'm using I know like the
[ __ ] air but the mist mud had AIDS
and [ __ ] right - udg while this was
happening
no no it's just a venue okay but then
the venue was like they didn't have time
to move everything out but it was the
venue was mainly for sex but it wasn't
that order when you were DJing no no it
was a birthday party they just they just
wanted a place to ran out but it was
bizarre they're like yeah let's rent
this one yeah they got bit well here why
would you want to rent Yeah right
it was yeah I forgot what we were
talking about this is about sex parties
yes it's thinking society Joker and
Harley that's right okay no there we go
Joker his name is Dale 35 year old you
can't just give away the secret identity
well not telling you last name you know
you can look at it maybe that a lot in
the stomach
oh we laughed after
we pulled out of power Oh and Zita
Harley she got shot in the link so both
of them there it's not life-threatening
in our trucks but Dale did a Q wasn't
serious conditions it's not my first and
that's the worst way to let go about it
because you're having sex I think you
shot Lisa would we make it when they got
shot that's a good question
I'm pretty sure guys all day they report
that they were dressed as the village so
he was in costume he just had a dick
hanging yeah he had a peekaboo
drop it what my dick was a good and his
uh pubes were matching his hair oh maybe
that's what was happening there telling
to put his hands up but he couldn't cuz
you're covering your dick there reports
that he was like waving a gun at them or
something
not according to the clock they were
saying that he did have his toy gun out
and then toy gun yeah he was pointing my
gun at that maybe it was his dick or you
get a body cam on the phone yeah
I think it was his penis that was
pointed and they got so mad we shot him
so they both can I don't blame that I
never know a good feeling orgy and he
saw all these people [ __ ] and then he
couldn't put two and two together this
guy's in the middle [ __ ] any shoot
son that's why what they're reporting
they were in a mess maybe you would like
his ex or something
they were [ __ ] and then he pulled out
and he came on the officers face he got
mad economy oh that sounds morbid what
it is I you always got a she's my doctor
why'd you shoot my point for you too
[ __ ] Brown ha ha ha man well she got
shot too
yeah you got shot in the stomach she got
shot in the [ __ ] legs that she was
talking back after he shot me he was in
the heat of the moment he turned around
what right in the mouth what the [ __ ]
boom as you go you shot my boyfriend
[ __ ] boom [ __ ] in my mouth
he probably didn't say anything trying
to make sure that they come didn't go
inside come on changers come in your
mouth ah but abbadabba strangers is okay
yep yeah came on the officers face
that's like what biological warfare that
is you could get in so phone call could
have ease yeah I thought what a deadly
semen no cuz um you know what do you
call it inmates they [ __ ] and they like
let their [ __ ] rot or whatever you know
she a rot it I thought it came out and
they would dip like shanks and stuff
into that and they would window window
it like what you called the jailers
bring food or whatever they try to stab
their arm or whatever so they could get
infections and all that stuff yeah so
that's like biological warfare well I
don't know what they call it
specifically but that is a form of like
assault right that's like making that
poison
I just think sup you're a whole [ __ ]
cell if you do - nice somebody you
should get killed tonight I think you
should be like put on the electric chair
Masum that's a premeditated premeditated
murder that you you have to let that
[ __ ] marinate for a minute just to just
a dip it that's like some poison arrow
phone what's up you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] link to the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ] then that
videos are up there
[Music]
you